so for viewers at home who have a pet or
a dog specifically cats are a little bit
harder
um
the way you want to train a dog the best
way to do it is to
stay consistent with the words that you
use and the hand signals that you use
and then i always use the same
reinforcement i've taught him some
commands in german
because that's his native language
so if i say plots
uh so basically we just finished filming
the first scene here where rocky's in
the alley and he's trying to find food
um
and basically
what we had him do is we had him sit
down and jake calls his name so that he
kind of looks around at his stomach as
if it's gurgling and we're gonna put a
funny like stomach sound effect in there
later so hopefully it comes through
reflector is basically a way for you to
light something that's in shadow when
you have direct sunlight it's like sam
over here is in shadow when i take this
reflector
he looks like he's wet
hey
so reflector is just a big shiny
reflective piece of metal or not metal
a piece of like silver coated something
this is like a real photographer's uh
reflector it's got a green backside if
you want a cheap reflector just go to
like
home depot or something and get some the
uh insulation like foam core
that has like a silver side it's like
these big sheets they work great as a
reflector and they cost like 10 bucks
so we use a circular polarizer on our
lenses now basically light coming off of
the sky is polarized meaning that the
way it bounces off the sky causes it to
the light to take on a certain
uh direction of vibration it's kind of
hard to explain because i'm not a
physicist
anyways basically
if you look here at the image of the
camera as i spin the polarizer the
brightness of the sky changes see there
it's really dark
and there it's
really bright
so what this lets us do is uh
not change the brightness of the rest of
the scene but get a much more rich blue
sky
cinematography secrets
we'll uh play this next scene all in
essentially one big take uh we're gonna
have rocky we're gonna grab his collar
and have his shoulder in the edge of the
frame as amanda walks down the alley and
when she passes you that's when you look
at her you see that you have your
opportunity you'll stand up stalk her
for like a second or two and then just
go right for the purse you guys are
gonna struggle for a little bit but
eventually he's just gonna yank it off
and you're gonna just book it all the
way down the alley okay
wrapping my arm so that uh when rocky
bites my wrist he doesn't cut me
because you see that right there
that's from the other day when i didn't
wrap my arm well enough
and he
got his little
canine teeth in there and
got me pretty good hello
so i'm just gonna hold up my arm and
give him a command in german so that he
doesn't he doesn't ever hear it unless i
say it to him unless we're in germany uh
and he'll just attack my arm rocky
pack it
pack it we're the rocky attack jake yep
he's gonna bite his arm i've played with
him enough where he knows the drill
stuff
he should be fine
as though it does hurt for this shot
i'm i don't know what i'm going to be
seeing i'm going to be doing a full
circle around him so we kind of need a
360
like radius of safety here fast yeah all
right camera's rolling sam stay close to
jake
and
action
all right guys here's a cool trick for
you we shoot outdoors a lot so we always
rely on natural light now at the end of
the day it gets tough to figure out how
much light you have left so here's a
simple trick hold your arm out at arm's
length you have you make a fist and you
hold the fist below the sun and you keep
going and however many stacks of fists
you have is how many hours you have each
fist is an hour in terms of how long it
takes the sun to move across the sky
there you go anger is 15 minutes each
finger is 15 minutes
these latex strips that sam made to look
like arm guts
and then hopefully when we pull on them
they'll snap
and here's another shirt where we tore
off kind of tore off the sleeves so tear
easily
this is surprisingly
like this is going to sell really well
that guy just get his arm ripped off
holy [ __ ] bro hoping somebody sees it
and they totally freak out
there we go so that's some pretty good
hey how are you dude nice to meet you
nice to meet you pleasure uh we're
trying to basically sell this
shot of me getting my arm ripped off and
so we got a fake arm from a props shop
and we've covered it with the same shirt
and shirts that i was using and we've
got these latex uh
strands in there that basically look
like human flesh and blood and then
we're gonna put a bunch of fake blood in
there and when the arm comes out of the
oh and the arm is the shirt underneath
the black shirt is cut so that it'll rip
easier so it's gonna rip out and then
blood's gonna go everywhere and i'm
gonna scream
go for it
good there we go there we go we got it
you